Transcription: Laurence Patrigeon
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
Vous voyez cette feuille de papier ?
C'est un avis d'imposition,
c'est de la matière.
Démonstration.
Maintenant,
voici mon avis d’imposition dématérialisé.
Ce n'est pas de la matière.
Démonstration.
Mais vous affolez pas
Puisqu’on vous dit
que ce n’est pas de la matière.
Quoique, à bien y regarder,
il y a bien  un peu d’électronique.
Il y a bien un peu de plastique,
Il y a bien un peu de produits toxiques,
de l’arsenic, de l’antimoine, du brome,
du chlore, du cadmium, du lithium,
du plomb, du mercure, des phosphates.
Allez dire à un enfant au Ghana, à Accra,
qui démonte ces ordinateurs à mains nues
que c’est pas de la matière.
Il vous rira au nez parce que ce n’est pas
de dématérialisation dont il s’agit,
mais de démultiplication de la matière
En lieu et place de dématérialisation,
on ferait mieux de parler
de multimatérialisation
ou de plurimatérialisation.
Le dogme, plutôt, de la dématérialisation
a la peau dure.
Dire qu’on dématérialise
avec le numérique,
c’est un peu comme si on disait
qu’on peut procréer dans la virginité.
Alors, pourquoi j’ai utilisé cet exemple ?
Parce que je pose la question :
le numérique ne serait-il pas en train
de devenir une nouvelle religion ?
Qu’est-ce qui distingue
la science de la religion ?
Plusieurs éléments.
Nous allons en retenir trois.
Le premier ?
C’est que la science
procède par expérimentation
là ou la religion procède par la foi.
La science dit :
« Vois et seulement crois. »
La religion dit : « Crois sans voir. »
Ainsi les Évangiles nous rapportent
que Saint Thomas
ne croyait pas que Jésus était ressuscité.
Il a fallu qu’il le voie pour le croire.
Il a fallu qu’il le touche, qu’il touche
ses plaies pour le croire.
Et alors ?
Saint Thomas a procédé par expérience,
Jésus aurait dit :
« Heureux celui qui croit sans voir. »
C'est une invitation à l'obéissance,
pas à l'exercice de la science.
D’où cet exemple.
Si les prophètes du numérique
nous disent :
grâce au numérique,
nous décarbonons l’économie.
Grâce au numérique,
nous réalisons des économies d’énergie.
nous dématérialisons le monde.
Bref, grâce au numérique, nous allons
vers la transition écologique.
Faut-il le croire ?
Si on le croit, on peut foncer
vers toutes les innovations,
vers la 5G, vers la ville intelligente,
vers le tout connecté,
vers le tout numérique.
Et puis, si on n’y croit pas, eh bien,
on peut laisser choir son ordinateur
et voir comment cette non-matière
fait un non-bruit en ne chutant pas.
De toute façon, on vous dit,
il n’y a pas de matière.
Alors, deuxième élément qui distingue
la science de la religion,
ce sont les mythes.
Toute religion possède des mythes.
Nous allons voir que le numérique
possède plusieurs mythes.
Premier mythe associé au numérique,
le mythe du zéro déplacement.
Régulièrement,
quand une nouvelle TIC apparaît,
une TIC, une Technologie de l’Information
et de la Communication,
on nous dit que ça va supprimer
les déplacements.
C’était vrai déjà avec la visioconférence,
c’était vrai déjà avec le téléphone.
En 1876, le téléphone est inventé.
Le 10 mai 1879, un éditorialiste
du Times exulte.
Grâce à cette formidable innovation,
ça va pouvoir supprimer les déplacements,
puisque les managers ont juste besoin
de se parler par téléphone,
ils ont plus besoin de se voir.
Prophétie qui aurait été contredite
par le tout premier coup de fil
de l’humanité
qui aurait été donné
par Alexander Graham Bell lui-même,
l’inventeur du téléphone,
qui aurait pris son téléphone
pour appeler Watson,
son collaborateur, et lui dire :
« Watson, venez ici tout de suite,
j’ai besoin de vous. »,
générant ainsi un trajet.
En réalité, ce dont on se rend compte,
c’est que plus il y a de TIC,
plus il y a de communication
entre les gens
et plus il y a de transport de personnes.
Donc il n’y a pas un effet
de substitution,
mais il y a un effet de complémentarité.
Deuxième mythe associé au numérique,
le mythe de la zéro matière.
Il n’y a rien de moins vrai,
comme ce déchet à mes pieds
s’évertue à le montrer.
D’ailleurs, on n’est pas en train
de passer du matériel au virtuel.
On passe du virtuel au matériel.
Jamais il n’avait été possible
jusqu’à présent
de matérialiser autant de choses
qui restaient virtuelles par le passé.
Par exemple, vous réalisez
un post sur Facebook,
et puis finalement, vous vous révisez.
Non, le texte va pas,
vous décidez de supprimer,
vous en faites un autre,
celui-là, vous le publiez.
Pensez-vous que le premier post
que vous avez supprimé
est définitivement sorti
de la plateforme ?
Eh bien non !
Tant et si bien que des chercheurs du MIT
ont étudié 5 millions de posts
censurés par les utilisateurs
pour comprendre
le comportement des acteurs.
Dans quelle société était-il possible,
par le passé,
de matérialiser le cheminement
de la pensée des auteurs,
par ailleurs à leur insu ?
Autrefois, quand deux chefs de village
se querellaient sous un arbre à palabre,
les termes de la querelle
restaient dans les airs,
puis restaient un petit peu
dans les mémoires collectives.
Puis ça finissait par s'effacer
avec le temps.
Aujourd’hui, la querelle que vous avez
sur les réseaux sociaux, elle reste,
bien ancrée dans des fermes de données,
dans des lieux parfois tenus secrets.
Il y a eu une révolution
avec l’invention de l’imprimerie
qui a permis la matérialisation
de la pensée des écrivains.
Mais le processus restait maîtrisé
par les écrivains.
Aujourd’hui, il y a une nouvelle
révolution, la révolution du numérique.
Mais elle est différente
de par son processus de démocratisation
et par le fait que le processus
de matérialisation
de la pensée des auteurs
échappe au contrôle des acteurs.
Alors nous avons vu deux mythes :
le mythe du zéro déplacement,
le mythe de la zéro matière.
On va voir maintenant le mythe
de la zéro pollution.
Ça, c’est un mythe
qui ne tient pas la route
parce que le numérique pollue énormément.
Aujourd’hui, si Internet était un pays,
il serait le troisième consommateur
d’électricité
derrière les États-Unis et la Chine.
Aujourd’hui, le numérique pollue
un tiers de fois plus que l’aviation.
L’empreinte écologique du numérique
est un tiers de fois supérieure
à l’empreinte de l’aviation.
Donc le numérique pollue
et pollue énormément.
Et enfin, quatrième mythe associé
au numérique, le mythe du zéro papier.
Régulièrement quand une nouvelle TIC,
Technologie de l’Information
et de la Communication apparaît,
on dit aussi
que ça va supprimer le papier.
C’était vrai avec les emails,
et on a vu que ça n’a pas
supprimé le papier.
On consomme toujours plus de papier
et plus il y a de TICs,
plus il y a de communication
et plus il y a d’impression de papier.
Donc on a le même phénomène
qu'avec le transport.
Il y a un phénomène de complémentarité
et non pas de substitution.
D’ailleurs, on pourrait même
se poser la question :
est-il judicieux de vouloir remplacer
le papier par le numérique ?
À votre avis,
entre un livre lu sur papier
et un livre lu sur liseuse,
lequel est le plus écologique ?
Oui, le papier. En fait un livre
lu sur papier est plus écologique.
Le cabinet Carbone 4
a fait le calcul pour nous.
Et le livre…
Ça devient écologique de lire sur liseuse
à partir du 137ᵉ livre lu
donc si vous lisez que 136livres,
il vaut mieux les acheter
et les lire sur papier.
Je vous laisse calculer le nombre
de livres que vous lisez par an
et le nombre d’années qu’il faudrait
pour amortir la liseuse.
Et puis c’est sans compter
sur la fin de vie des outils.
Un livre papier, on sait le recycler,
on sait bien faire.
Ce n'est pas un problème.
Le livre numérique,
ça, c’est une autre paire de manches.
Aujourd’hui, qu’est-ce qu’on fait
de nos déchets numériques ?
Seuls 10 à 20% des déchets numériques
sont gérés de façon responsable
dans le monde.
Le reste, 80%, c’est soit déchargé
sans prétraitement dans les décharges,
soit envoyé aux États-Unis, pardon
envoyé aux États-Unis, ça serait bien !
(rire)
soit envoyé dans les pays pauvres,
le plus souvent en Afrique.
Quand ils sont jetés sans prétraitement
dans les décharges,
ils finit par pleuvoir sur ces déchets.
Il pleut sur nos ordinateurs.
Il pleut sur les composants
qu’il y a dans les ordinateurs,
sur l’arsenic, sur le plomb,
sur le mercure, vous vous souvenez ?
Tous ces composants, ces métaux lourds,
ils finissent par entrer
dans la nappe phréatique.
Ils finissent par entrer dans la terre.
La nappe phréatique, la terre va alimenter
nos légumes que nous allons manger.
Donc nous mangeons nos ordinateurs.
Ce ne sont plus des ordinateurs portables,
ce sont des ordinateurs pour table.
Et quand nos déchets…
(quelques applaudissements)
Et quand les déchets ne sont pas
simplement jetés dans les décharges,
ils sont envoyés à l’étranger.
Ainsi, les États-Unis,
à eux seuls, exportent
80 % de leurs déchets électroniques
à l’étranger.
Au cours de mes pérégrinations,
j’ai vu des femmes et des enfants
démonter des ordinateurs à mains nues.
Je les ai vus inhaler,
brûler les composants,
inhaler le contenu sans masque.
Je peux vous dire que
ça fait quelque chose.
Alors nous avons vu la différence
entre science et religion.
La différence, c’est l’expérience…
La science procède par expérimentation
là où la religion procède par la foi.
Nous avons vu que la religion
possède des mythes.
Nous allons maintenant
nous intéresser au doute.
« Voici le Livre,
Il ne contient aucun doute. »,
nous dit le Coran,
Sourate deux, verset deux.
« Le doute détruit la personne. »,
nous dit Rabbi David Pinto
dans un de ses cours de Torah en ligne.
« Heureux celui qui croit sans voir. »
nous dit Jésus-Christ.
Le scientifique, lui,
est convaincu de ses doutes,
un peu moins de ses certitudes.
Quand il n’y a plus de doute,
on nage dans la croyance.
Et au nom de la croyance
dans la religion du numérique,
on fonce tête baissée
vers le tout numérique.
On fonce, sans plus faire
d'analyse d'impact.
Sans principe de précaution,
sans plus faire d’analyse des besoins,
sans plus faire d’analyse ex ante.
On fonce, on fonce
dans toutes les administrations, partout.
Et il y a un domaine que je connais bien,
c’est celui de l’enseignement supérieur
puisque je suis enseignante chercheuse.
Et là, c’est un domaine
où les directives pleuvent
pour que les enseignants
aillent vers le tout numérique.
Un exemple :
à partir de 2012, on a commencé à équiper
les élèves de première année
d’école d’enseignement supérieur
d’un iPad.
Dans une de ces écoles
où j’ai pu faire une expertise,
on nous disait que on introduisait l’iPad
pour le développement durable.
Alors j'ai fait une expertise avec
plusieurs étudiants de cette même école
et j’ai pu montrer que l’iPad
ne permettait pas
la transition écologique.
Alors la direction a changé
le fusil d’épaule et a dit,
alors on va dire que c’est pour
l’innovation pédagogique,
alors processus de rationalisation.
Mais qu’en est-il ?
Qu’en est-il réellement
de l’efficacité des iPads ?
Alors pour répondre à cette question,
j’ai mis une étudiante en thèse
sur le sujet.
Pendant cinq ans, elle a étudié le sujet.
Pendant 1600 heures,
elle s’est fait passer
pour une étudiante.
Elle est rentrée dans différentes écoles.
Elle rentrait dans les salles de classe
et elle se mettait systématiquement
au fond de la salle de classe,
au fond de l’amphi.
Et elle regardait ce que faisaient
réellement les étudiants
avec l’iPad distribué par l’école.
J'ai peur de vous annoncer les résultats.
Ils sont édifiants.
En moyenne,
sur une heure et demie de cours,
les étudiants passent une heure
à se distraire avec l’outil.
Ils sont sur Facebook, sur Messenger,
ils jouent à des jeux vidéos,
ils regardent des vidéos,
ils regardent des photos.
Sur une heure et demie de cours,
une heure à se distraire avec l’outil.
l'iPad est un outil de distraction
et d'éloignement du savoir.
Eh bien, allez dire ça aux directions
qui ont introduit des iPads.
Qu’est-ce qu’elle va vous répondre ?
On va pérenniser l’opération,
on va encore en faire plus
et distribuer plus et continuer.
Vous vous dites, on est
dans un monde de fous.
Si vous dites, vous apportez des faits
comme quoi ça ne marche pas,
on vous répond :
« mais tu ne crois en rien. »
On est dans la religion du numérique.
Et alors là, il n’y a plus de logique.
Mais si il y a une logique
et cette logique, on la comprend
si on change de paire de lunettes.
Et si je vous révèle quel est ce dieu
que vénère la religion du numérique ?
Eh bien ce dieu,
c’est le dieu Croissance.
Et les tables de la Loi
auraient pu tomber
dans la Silicon Valley,
tant il est vrai que le numérique
permet à la croissance de s’exprimer.
Quelles sont ces tables de la loi ?
Quels sont ses dix commandements ?
Premièrement, tu travailleras.
Deuxièmement, tu consommeras.
Troisièmement, tu gaspilleras.
Quatrièmement, tu travailleras plus.
Cinquièmement, tu consommeras plus.
Sixièmement, tu gaspilleras plus.
Septièmement, tu ne partageras pas.
Et enfin, les trois derniers commandements
ajoutés par le prophète
Développement Durable.
Huitièmement, tu consommeras
de préférence des produits verts.
Neuvièmement, étant donné
que ces produits sont verts,
tu en consommeras sans modération.
Et enfin, dixièmement,
tu ne blasphèmeras pas
à propos du Dieu Croissance,
de l’Esprit-Saint Consommation
et du fils de Dieu le Sauveur,
le Développement Durable.
Le développement durable :
cette pensée crétinisée qui met
de la vaseline au mot de développement
dont elle ne reconnaît pas les carences.
Jolie phrase non ?
Ce n’est pas de moi, je n’aurais pas osé.
(applaudissements)
C’est une phrase d’Edgar Morin :
« Le développement durable,
cette pensée crétinisée qui met
de la vaseline au mot de développement
dont elle ne reconnaît pas les carences. »
Le développement durable, cet oxymore,
tant il est vrai que le développement
ne peut pas être durable.
Justement, tout est bon pour renforcer
les logiques de croissance
ou de développement.
Et c’est là que le numérique
représente une aubaine,
vient à-propos
dans une société de consommation
qui présente des signes d’essoufflement
parce qu’elle lui permet de lui donner
un second souffle surtout,
surtout si les consommateurs citoyens
rentrent dans les ordres sans broncher.
Pour l'instant, il s'agit
de vœux de transparence.
Demain, peut-être de soumission
et d’obéissance,
comme c’est déjà un peu le cas en Chine.
Alors, tout comme Dieu a besoin
des êtres humains pour exister,
la croissance a besoin du numérique
qui  est un secteur innovant
par excellence.
Or l’innovation permet l’obsolescence
et l’obsolescence
est la condition de survie
de l’économie de marché
basée sur la croissance.
Alors,
pour l’instant,
nous avons encore le choix.
Tant qu’il en est encore temps,
gardons les yeux ouverts.
sachons débusquer les ressorts
de l’essor du numérique.
Tant qu’il en est encore temps,
ne fonçons pas tête baissée,
tels des bovidés.
Tant qu'il en est encore temps,
sachons résister.
« Je suis athée, Dieu merci. »,
disait Lichtenberg.
En ce qui nous concerne, à l’instar
des athées, soyons « athiques ».
Merci.
(applaudissements)